so whenever my mom goes tonight cheering
I always have her bring me back some
friends cuz it makes me feel tough sit
at home and I just love to mix African
Prince I think there's nothing like it
in the 80s everything that I'm wearing
from 125th Street but African print has
always been in because it comes straight
from the motherland and if you don't
know you better ask somebody and I wear
African Prince all today to represent my
culture I grew up attending cruel to my
whole life I'm celebrating my
[ __ ] heritage and I'm happy
where my mom sold African print for 35
years so that was the only thing I knew
the most that's how I showed how
different I was my outfits from East
Africa more specifically something near
too often we forget we're really coming
from Africa we still have all this
culture ingrained in us wearing these
types of styles absolute feel like I am
a little bit closer to home no I live
here I have another home in Tanzania yes
it makes me feel connected Samaritan
it's loud it's proud it's brilliant so
it's like being able to have a little
bit of home everywhere I go even if
you're born here first generation second
third generation you should always make
sure that you're connected to your
heritage because in order to know where
you're going you must know where you
come from and wearing these prints and
collectively understanding the story and
the messaging behind the prints
understanding the significance of
representing our culture representing
our continent
[Music]
you